boh il ragazzo allora ce lo siamo
sentiti dire tutti quanti penso trovo
che questa premessa sinceramente sia la
cosa più ridicola che la razza umana si
è inventata nel corso della storia
e così assurda come cosa da dire così
ovviamente paok rita che mi chiedo il
perché le persone continuano ancora ad
usarla senza vergogna seleziona frase
con scusa non per essere aggiungendo
dopo un qualsiasi aggettivo negativo e
poi miss fani una crudeltà assurda io
personalmente non ti crederò mai
quando dico mai dico mai poi scusate
dovrebbe essere stronze ma nella tua
ragazza sta facendo una svolta nella con
remo annesso ma ma la mia ragazza non è
anche la tua migliore amica
no ma infatti era nulla non è che il suo
fratello
sì ma infatti intende voti sembrano a
cosa allora adesso se non è per essere
stronzi per che cos'è ma io apprezzerei
molto di più di gran lunga di più che
proprio da lettere di strette di mano
adesso un'app invece di farvi questa
intro idiota mi facesse quest'altro tipo
dentro 20 nel cast non seppe fatto kohl
a compiere test del caso ma storia
venete samp erano un prato e quanto nei
fiori bile testa al mondo tesoro e
lasciatelo dire cioè dovresti
sopprimerlo e se non hai le palle di
sopprimere straw candelino col cappello
c'è dovrebbero non investirlo eco
investino quando a volte a fare
passeggiatina peccato rospo schifoso
mappa non va bene via schifoso ma che
c'è un marasma sposo vere che è ma che
accade sta merda per il piacere dei
frati ad hera in questo modo senza
problemi
essendo così chiara mi dà la possibilità
di risponderti con un
brutta faccia il culo perché di solito
in questi casi quando le persone fanno
questo tipo di promessa la persona che
riceve la mazzata o risponde
direttamente con maggior favore per non
dare la vita fanno finta di sbatter sarà
altamente sentite son belle frasi quello
delle insidie però sta mette su chi è ma
che su quelli che invece non lascia
installando che permette ribadisce
all'orsa bianca del discovery channel di
superarli inverno e dai e così fa schifo
se lo son telo darci io sto un pò giù ma
altro che qui da tanto lo so che lui me
lo dici per cattiveria non guarda 7
serviti da dietro sembri non nast amici
ed è proprio a volta stesa avevo capito
che detto che non è un periodo felice
appunto fine del discorso
sì però che devo dire io allora che
sommesi rete pd quella sceglie roba che
per me invece alle chiamate ram e rom
sono su quei cose che piacere maglione
tesoro e poi c'è qualche ipocrisia non
breve linee molto di più teso verso una
bella vacca come so io che esse schiave
is bianca mi canali come siete ed ai è
che non so
diciamocelo non abbiamo fatto abbiamo
perso cioè non c'è più è una cosa che
prima c'era e adesso non c'è il tatto è
le persone non riescono più a interagire
fra di loro è ancora più divertenti sono
quelle che invece sono sincere non
lamentano questa premessa e ti fanno una
cosa tipo così no io questa prevista non
le faccio sinceramente per fortuna no
per esempio tu sei uno scaldabagno per
quanto sembra tutto ma la tua madre per
caso ha avuto con un tricheco ma perché
sì forse una vera e sincera ma remember
ecco non ho potuto finire di dire che
questo tipo di persone se è possibile
sono ancora peggiori di quelle prime
perché perché facendo così facendo le
persone sinceri si permettono di dirti
le peggio cattiverie e non so si sentono
di poter le specie di portatori di
sailor moon della verità ha capito
quello che dico io è la verità
no quello che dici tu non è la verità io
ti sto però comunque i ragazzi sono
sicuro che anche a voi sarà successo
2008 incontrare persone così amorevoli
quindi cosa aspettate a farci sapere
cosa del successo lasciando un
commentino qua sotto
oppure se proprio vivamente mettendo un
videocommento in risposta con scenette
cazzatine varie per farci ridere un po a
tutti e non mi dite no no mi vergogno di
un o poi ricevo commenti di odio perché
molto molto meglio che le persone ci
mandino a cagare su youtube che nella
vita reale ok ciao a tutti